I think it's an important distinction to
make and this is why the left cannot
come to agreements this is where we
can't find common ground we can't see
eye to eye if we're not even starting
with the same premise as to what a right
is and we'll go through a few examples
and I would like to see your comments
here on youtube or send us your tweets
at s Crowder at Aetna K Jared with what
you think our actual rights versus
commodities understanding the difference
so what is a right let's define this
first it's a just claim or title whether
legal prescriptive or moral according to
dictionary.com now in the USA the beauty
of that is it's prescribed by the
Constitution so we say well how is it
legal prescriptive so it can be
different but human rights they're based
in natural rights in the USA they're
prescribed clearly in the Constitution
okay what's a commodity now to clarify
nuts people so a commodity tends to be a
raw sort of resource like iron ore or
gold we're using a broader definition
here the economic commodities ok
economic commodities and services in
economics a commodity is a marketable
item produced to satisfy wants or needs
and it can comprise of either goods or
services so this is where I think we
have some disconnects let's go through
some examples of things that people
assume our rights human right to health
care health care ok what's your right
you have the right to take any legal
measures you deem necessary to insure
your own personal health that includes
access ability to purchase services of
your choosing no one should be able to
impede you from seeking the healthiest
life possible there you go that seems
what's a commodity well a drug a
treatment or services created at the
risk or investment of a business owner
like health insurance programs based
around the concept of an aggregated risk
pool balance with offsetting costs and
premiums or deductibles the average
annual cost of health care is about ten
thousand I think something ten thousand
something dollars or other statin funny
that's a commodity hey I have a right to
health sure you have a right to be
healthy I have a right to your advil no
you know you have to pay for Advil why
because someone paid to create that
Advil that's a commodity education
that's declare to right often from the
left okay what's your right sure you
have a right to educate yourself I think
we can all agree on that to learn to be
unempioyed in pursuing your higher
education thereof or your personal
education that's your
right but what would be a commodity a
degree maybe from a university whose
cost is determined based on a quality of
teaching track records of a graduate
their viability is the flexibility of
the services officer offered by the
school the average annual cost to in
public state colleges some around twenty
five thousand I think a private college
is close to fifty thousand so again that
costs somebody something yeah it costs
the professor he had to get a degree he
had to get training to become highly
specialized to teach at Harvard you do
not have it you have a right to educate
yourself go to the library read on the
internet use Bing if you want whatever
your preference is you don't have a
right to force somebody else to teach
you free right commodity okay let's go
to Internet we just had Thomas Haslett
to talk about net neutrality so this one
seems to be confusing to people let's go
through a medial you have the right sure
with the internet to be unimpeded in the
purchase of Internet access and I would
even say including protection from
dishonest inhibitory actions from an
Internet service provider good thing is
those are already protected yeah and I
tree have these with monopoly laws in
the government right now so that would
be your right to go get the internet
that you want the internet plan that you
want that is your right what's a
commodity the internet or broadband
access packages themselves now a key
term anecca now it's excludable that
means non paying consumers can't access
it and rival Oris means that additional
consumers increased the cost
significantly that's when net neutrality
matters these terms excludable rivals
tend to reoccur when it comes to dealing
with commodities metal gauge beautiful
free yeah you don't get on there for
free don't get HBO go for free
contraceptives this is a new one
contraceptive that's right right it's a
human right contraceptives okay well
let's even go with this you have the
right to access and purchase any
contraceptives of your choosing all
agree no one should bar you from buying
one buying a rubber at a truck stop or
an IUD I don't care what's a commodity
the contraceptive birth control pills
condoms IUDs they don't just fall out of
the sky someone invented them often a
man so this is the right protects your
ability to pursue something a right
almost never guarantees or forces
somebody else to provide you with
something yes that's important and we've
got an office of beaming with
contraceptives well that's only the
extreme leftist social justice warrior
so okay let's go to one that see almost
everyone seems on board with
water people that should be the most
basic human right is water okay sure
you're right what is your right to have
the right to consume or utilize any non
privately-owned water I don't think
anyone should be barred from accessing
water the Antelope can go get water he
risks being torn apart by a lion and
that makes for great TV but it's his
right now what would be a commodity oh
maybe water itself if it's filtered
sanitized pumped directly into your
place of dwelling through an intricate
system of pipes and technology it didn't
happen for free you have the right to
water you don't have the right to force
somebody to pay to clean and sanitize
your water it matters because everyone
has some kind of a lens through which
they see the world the ISM matters and
if you look at actually on the flip side
rights that conservatism fights for
rights that right now conservatives are
fighting for most actively I think it
would probably agree conservatives when
you're talking about rights they're most
actively fighting right now for probably
probably freedom of speech and guns yeah
those are two big issues protection of
life I would say yeah protection of life
yeah okay yeah so let's start with
freedom of speech
all right so conservatives are actively
fighting for that right well okay first
off how do you know it's your right
where is that proscribed up I'm Emmett
number one all right bring the speech
it's in the Constitution it actually
talks about free speech now here's
something to that's important to note
when conservatives fight for freedom of
speech even if you see the controversy
with YouTube having censored some of our
content or Facebook you'll see a lot of
conservatives say they actually have the
right to do that and we agree with that
they just don't have the right to lie to
consumers about it bad business
practices that's a different issue but
conservatives understand that we have
the right to speak freely and are
fighting it's a right that the left
doesn't believe in they don't believe in
it professors don't believe it now I'm
not just talking about in specific areas
or instances they don't believe in a
generalized absolute right to free
speech we do when we're fighting for it
we're fighting for the right to speak
freely fully understanding that we are
not going to be paid to speak freely
look at guns what do we believe okay we
believe that we have the right to keep
and bear that it's a right that liberals
don't believe it right so this is
important the Funt stay with me here we
believe that we have the right to own
and keep guns well where'd you get that
from well it's amendment number two so
right now we're just going through
number one and two sweetheart
right you're still tracking this with
odds ok so there's at least you we're
making the declarative statement we have
the right to keep and bear arms that's
the right we fight for in like freedom
of speech we're just fighting for the
ability to have them we're not
protesting Smith & Wesson to give us
free guns and that's a fundamental
difference in worldly because we look at
the rights that then liberals declare
that their rights a healthcare education
water shelter basic universal income
right you say well how do you know those
are rights uh I will just file it all
under the general welfare clause it's
nowhere in the Constitution the scribe
are there by name
there's don't even exist but let's even
go with it ok you put under the general
welfare clause sure ok you have the
right to pursue health care of course
yeah yeah we believe in the right to
access to water sure you have the right
to purchase birth control no they are
taking rights that don't exist filing
them under a term that was not meant for
that and then fighting for the right to
force you and I to pay for it through
our tax dollars that is a fundamental
worldview difference the rights that are
outlined and prescribed as per our legal
documents they don't even believe exist
what about freedom of speech it's hate
speech what about the Second Amendment
roommate's too much money
oh so you don't believe those are rights
no I think I should have a right to a 25
cent Robert a truckstop and you should
pay for it this is something that
matters so much because if you start off
from a point where you don't even
understand the difference between a
right or a commodity
I don't just gets to you were placed
right with something I want
oh then rights would be ever-changing
and guess what things that rights would
infringe on other rights because
everyone has different things that they
want right when I was a teenager I
wanted Elle Macpherson and my wall post
her to come to life but it wasn't my
right her should feel like her right she
should she should that is important you
can send some other examples if you
think that I'm wrong
rights versus economic commodities
anytime someone just says some things
are right and they declare it call them
on it
well where do you find that and how do
you justify it most of the time they can
the clip from the full show Daily Show
at ladder with credit calm / mug club or
it's available exclusively 69 dollars a
year that's less than six dollars a
month less than two expensive cups of
coffee or you can feed an African child
but just buy coffee or join the mug club
Daily Show ladder with credit.com / mug
club see you there
don't feed children